says well I've checked all the Bible
versions none of them say declare it all
says he says he doesn't know very clear
the term no is that in all of them
declare is none of them consider have no
know look perceive see visual tell
[Applause]
is God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
If you believe in the Trinity, what it
is and let's start with that. Sure.
Okay. So, the Trinity, ladies and
gentlemen, I'm going to speak a little
lower cuz my voice is a little tired
after all this cooking.
I'm still strong. Alhamdulillah. That's
man. You're used to this, man. You're a
vet. You're a better I'm strong. You're
a veteran. That's what happens when
you're a bad chef. You start complaining
when your food is done. This is tough,
man. Um so what the trinity is it's this
is the concept the concept is that God
the essence of God consists of three
distinct persons you have the father who
is the head or the source of the divine
essence and he eternally generates the
son and spirates the spirit because God
is relational and because he is love at
his foundation at his in his essence it
is necessary that God in his essence is
relational without depending on
something outside of himself which shows
that the father will beget another
person inspirate another person to have
full cooperative perfect love. So this
is what the trinity is. The concept that
god exists as three distinct persons.
The father as the source who uh uh uh
eternally generates the son and spirates
the spirit. Never done in time. That's
the trinity. Are you are you orthodox?
Got it. What what model do you follow?
What model of the trinity? Uh the
monarchial trinity. The monarch. Okay.
So orthodorox question. Yeah. Uh just
the monarch trinity. Do you know what do
you know what aseti means? Yeah. What
does it mean? Uh aseti is uh
selfexistence. Right. Okay. Is Jesus
self-existing? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, he
doesn't need the father to generate him
eternally. Well, if you're talking about
a say in regards to the essence, he has
a say. He doesn't rely on anything
outside of his own essence to uh to
exist. Now, when you're talking about
the economy, when you're talking about
the relations within the persons, then
he is begotten from the father. Aseti is
not the roles. Aseti is the nation. Oh,
no. It's with the essence. So, if the
father like you said, you you admitted
this. Uh-huh. When I ask you about the
definition of the trinity, you said the
father eternally generates the son. The
son. Okay. Can the son be generated
without the father? Can the son be
generated without the father? No, that
doesn't happen. That's so he doesn't
have a say because like No, that's
that's hypothetic though. Hold on. Say
like you said when I ask you for the
definition means selfexisting. Okay.
Yes. In in in regards to the essence.
Sure. Yeah. That's what I'm saying. It's
is something which is ontological roles.
Okay. Okay. So if you're talking, this
is why I said this. When you're talking
about the trinity, you got to understand
the categories you're talking. If you're
talking ontologically,
well, okay. If you're saying it's always
ontological, then don't switch over to
talking hypothetic. You did cuz when you
cuz when you look, this is the this is
the problem he's doing. He says that
when he's talking about a say, he's
talking about ontology, the nature, the
essence, right? So according to the
essence, Jesus is has a say because his
divine essence is the same as the
father, which is self-existent. Yes, it
is. Right? Hold on, let me finish. But
when you But then you asked me, okay,
can the son be generated without the
father? Now you're not talking about
ontology. You're talking about hypoatic
properties. Now, so now you're talking
about the relation between the father
and the son. So you're not talking about
ontology. You're talking about hypoatic
relations. I'm not hypothetic here
applies to whom? The father or the son?
Hypo a hypo. So this in this context.
Okay. So let me let me break down what
hypothetic is. Okay. Hypostasis regards
is the underlying reality of the
essence. And so it's the
rational be that the father is the only
one who generates. The son does not
generate. But when you let me let me
just break this down. When you're saying
the father generates the son, you're
talking about the the existence. No,
you're talking about relational
properties which is hypothetic.
Absolutely wrong. What what is
hypothesis? What is that? You said hold
on. You said aset is something which is
selfexistent. Yes. How is that
hypothetical? Oh, I I just told you. You
I'm just telling you if you're you said
that that ai always has to do with
ontology your essence. So since it
always has to do with the essence, then
because Jesus has the same essence as
the father, he is assay. He's
self-existent. Self-existent. Yes. So he
doesn't need the father. When you do
that, notice what you're doing. What I'm
doing is exactly what you're switching.
You're switching categories. So answer
the question. I just did. Okay. That's
Let's break it down into understand. Do
you know what hypothesis is? No. Hold
on. The father is he self-existent. Yes.
Who generates the father? No. No one
generates the father. That's that's
hypothetic though. Wait, wait, wait
wait right wait right wait right wait
right wait right wait right wait right
wait right wait right wait no that's his
essence self that's that's his
hypothesis as well selfexisting yes if
you record it look if you play Greek
words it's up to you but the fact is
self-existent in English means what that
you don't want anyone else to be your
source he said very clearly the source
is the father of what of Jesus of of the
essence right of Jesus of the essence of
his so so so guess what so hold on let
let him talk okay I mean if you want to
jump in I'm fine it's okay so look do do
you do you know what do you know Do you
know what hypostasis is? You just said
the nature of essence. No, no, no.
That's not hypoasis. No.
So, no. No. Hypoasis is the personhood.
It deals it deals with the persons.
Okay. And and and their relations with
each other. Okay. So, what about the
person? Wait. What about the person?
Okay. So, it talk when you're dealing
with hypoasis, it deals with the
relations that the persons have with
each other. So, generation is a
hypothetic property of the father. The
being generated is a hypothetic property
of the son. Okay. What does mean? All
right. If we're agreeing, if we're
talking about Hold on, let me finish.
Okay. Okay. If if you mean by
a meaning self ontological
self-existence, that means that your
your essence is self-existent. It's not
dependent on nothing else outside of
your own essence. Okay. So, with that
being said, that definition, then Jesus
is aay because he has the same essence
as the father. No, hold on. So, you're
saying you already agreed with me that
let's start with again, guys. Guys, we
can't hear when you guys are debating.
Sorry. Yeah, guys, leave. Yeah. Come on,
guys. Asi selfexisting means you don't
depend on anyone else in regard to that.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. About his
existence. Forget about this word play.
Essence, hypothetic, none of that. It
matters. We said no. It matters. Do you?
Okay. Can you can you exist without your
parents? No. Good. So, you're dependent
or you are now guys, please. I am
onlogically dependent on my parents.
Yes. You're contingent upon your
parents. Yes. Ontologically, is Jesus
contingent about the father? Not
ontologically. This is the point. Like
the way you're dependent on your
parents. Not ontologically. Source.
Ontologically. Not
ontologically. The source. Who is the
source of Jesus? Okay, I'll I'll say it
again. Like your source is your parents.
Who is the source of Jesus? No, it's not
the same. I'll tell you why. Notice I am
ontologically by nature dependent on my
parents. They have a distinct essence
than I do. Right? They are a different
human being than I am. Right. Right. I
know we have the same human. Am I am I
the Are we identical in our essence? No.
No. I said we are both human essence.
Are we the same human being? No, you're
not. Okay. So, we are different. I am a
different human being than my parents
and I am dependent on them for my
existence. Right. To come into the
truth. Okay. So, you're talking about
ontological being your essence what you
are. Okay. If your essence or your being
is dependent on another being to exist,
then you are not assay. meaning you are
not selfexistent. Okay. Now let me let
me break this down. Okay. When it comes
to the trinity because the father and
the son and the spirit have the same
essence. They have the same being that
means together they are selfexistent.
Jesus hold on let me finish. Jesus does
not rely on another being for his
existence. Okay. Okay. All right. Go
ahead. The father is the same being. No
it's not the same. Does he rely? Is he
the same person? No. Okay. You okay? Now
watch watch this. You said the father is
not the same person as a son, right? You
are not the same same person as your
parents. Correct. Right. Do you exist
yourself or are you contingent upon your
father? Okay. And you keep complaining.
I I'll say it again. No, no, no. I'll
say it again. I'm not complaining. You
need to answer the question. Are you
dependent on your parents to bring you
into existence? Okay. Yes. Because I am
a different Let me show you why. because
I have a I am a different I am a
different being than my parents. So as a
being as my own individual being I rely
on other beings to exist. So therefore
I'm not self-existent. However, when it
comes to Jesus, he is the same exact
identical being as the father. So let me
tell you, look, I did not ask you about
what kind of person Jesus is or the
father. Just like Just like I did not
ask you I don't understand why you don't
understand. Simple logic. Just like you
don't understand it, bro. Just like you
don't
even listen listen just like I didn't
ask you what what are you and what is
your father and mother? I didn't ask you
that. I asked you said the source and
this was at the very beginning of this
discussion. He said the source is the
father. Yes. The source is the father.
This is the source of what? Of Jesus and
the essence. No his existence. He says
eternally generating is an action.
Eternal generation is an action or not?
Yeah, it's a it's a relational action
with the son and the father. Okay. Who
does the action? Uh so the father
eternally generates the sun. That's
hypothetic. Can the son that's a
hypoatic property? Not not of the
essence. Can the son do that? Generate.
That's not what he does. No, that's not
his hypothe. So we know that they have
different roles and the existence depend
on different things. No. Oh my goodness.
The
father not the father doesn't depend on
let him finish. Let him finish. Let him
finish. The father does not depend on
anyone for his existence. The very
definition of the termi is selfexistent.
He already said the son cannot generate
the father but the father generates the
son. Which clearly shows that this is
not just a role. This is for their very
existence. Jesus needs the father
otherwise he can't be generating him
forever. Can he? I don't even know what
that means generating someone forever.
That means he hasn't fully been
generated or what? Okay. These are the
languages which are not found in the
Bible. Okay. All right. So, um, do you
know the difference between a being and
a person? Yeah, I tell you. You said,
"Yeah, I tell you." You tell me. I said,
"So you so you don't know?" I know, but
you tell me. No, no, no. So, I need you
cuz I need to know that that you know.
What is the difference between being and
personhood? They can be the same
actually.
Yes.
Are you a person? Okay. Is a Is a person
a being? Is a person a being? Yes, a
person has be. He say what he said. A
person a person has being however hold
on hold on. Would you would you say that
a rock is a being? So a rock is not a
being. Well, okay. All right, hold on.
Hold on. Let's being a being is
something. Okay, like for example, if
you he agreed that the person is a being
something that exists. A person has been
something that exists. Does a rock
exist? Yeah. But hold on. When you're
talking in context, hold on. When you're
talking in context of a person, you
differentiate between a living being and
a what? and a non-living. A non-living
what? Non-living entity. What is that? A
non-living what? What? Okay. So, a
person is a being. Wait, just answer the
question. You can differentiate between
a living being and a non-living being.
Very good. Okay. So, so, so a rock is a
non-living being, right? Yeah. Okay.
Good. So, now it has existence. That's
what I was saying. Very good. I agree.
Right.
What's so funny?
By the way, the Christians the
Christians believe in three persons in
one being or three beings in one person.
Okay. Okay. Okay. We're going to get
three in one. So, so no. All right. So,
listen. We're finally making way. So
guys, guys, guys. Okay. So, we
understand now that a rock is a being.
Is a rock a person? No. Very good. So,
there's a distinction between a being
and personhood, right? Yeah. There is a
difference. Yeah. Very good. So we talk
in context relative to what? Relative to
whatever we're talking about. Why you
moving away from my point? I'm not. I'm
on your point. I'm Where's your
self-existence? You know Jesus is not
self-existent. Hashem, he asked about
the nature. We're not. Come on. Hashem
about the nature of Jesus. Hashem, come
on. Stay. Hey, stay there. You need to
answer the question. Stay there. Answer
the question. Stay there. Stay. Okay.
Answer the question. Okay. So, look. So,
now that we know the reason why we had
to even get this far is because you
didn't know the difference between being
a person. You said they were the same. I
said existence. I know, but you didn't
even know that the definition in terms
of the context. Okay. So, look. So, you
need to understand. So, now I very
clearly said existence. So, now we're in
So, so we're on the same page now. You
know what it means? No, I said
existence, right? Before you told me.
All right. No worries. We're we're on
the same page now. Okay. So, now we're
on the same page. So, when we're talking
about your being, you're talking about a
is related to the being, right? Not
personhood. It's a property of being.
That's what you're saying. Correct. No.
So you're saying a is relevant to the to
the person. Okay. So not the being. Not
the being. Okay. So a say you said this
is what this is what you said earlier.
You said that a say is it has to do with
your onlogical existence. When you say
ontological that has to do with your
being not your personhood. Okay. So if
you're talking about in terms of each
person okay their existence in the case
of the father he's self-existence hence
he's assay. Okay. The son for his
existence like you said you understand
the term being. Yeah. Is a is a is a son
a being. The son is a being. Yes. Yeah.
He's the same being that the father is.
And the father is a being. They're the
same being. I didn't ask you the same.
Yeah. They are a being. They are the
same being. Okay. Are they distinct?
They're distinct persons. Persons. Okay.
Now, for the existence of each of these
distinct persons. Okay. Okay. Who is the
source? Oh my goodness. Who's the
source? Oh, Lord have mercy. Look, now
you're on the same page. Simple as that.
You're not Look, you you were on the you
were Look, you were on the same page and
then you turned it. No, no, you're
panicking. I need to correct you. But oh
my goodness, you you keep switching from
when it when talking about being and
personhood. You think you think that
properties of being are being applied to
person and you don't even know you're
doing that. So, I'm trying to show you
that you're doing this. Is predicated to
what? To a person. I thought it was a
person's existence. No, but early No,
stop. Satan is predicated to a person's
existence. Read my lips. Okay. Because
this guy here is a person lift up now
because you realize you know Hashem.
Hashem is a person's existence is that
you need to answer my question. No. No.
Cuz we need to define terms. I asked you
a question. Answer my question. But you
need to define terms bro. Yes I did.
You're misapplying terms. We have
already defined. But I know and you
contradicted yourself already. No. I
said for a person his uh the aet is
predicated to a person's existence. Yes
or no? What do you mean? What? Oh my
goodness. Existence is being. Yeah. But
is it dep is it predicated to the
person's existence? Yes or no? It's a
it's existence. Okay. If you're talking
about assay, right? Yes. According to
your definition earlier, you said that
is an onlogical property. So that means
it's not a personal property. It's not a
hypothetic procity to a person. So no,
it's it's it has to do with the essence,
not the person. Has to do with the
essence. I say predicated to a person's
existence. Yes. If it's if you just said
it
again because you really Oh my goodness.
You keep it. You keep it. Oh my god.
Give me that.
All right. So, so look this is this is
the issue. Hashem
the answer the answer is yes.
is predicated to a person's existence.
Yes. What does that mean? Just like I
told you, you're the person. Your
existence is predicated to your parents.
No. Can you exist without your parents?
Okay. Look, if you're talking about my
being, my being is dependent on two
people getting together, right? Let's
use the term existence because right now
we're confusing it because of the terms.
Your existence depends on whom? Yes.
Your existence depends on whom? My my
existence depends on my parents. Good.
Jesus's existence depends on whom? Jesus
existence is independent. Answer the
question. I just did. Okay. Can Jesus
exist without the father generating him?
So no. Okay. No. Notice what he just
did. Notice what he just did. Okay.
Look. Okay. Hold on.
Notice without the father. Stop. Stop.
Notice what you just did. Now so now at
first he he said, "Okay, let's talk
about just being existence cuz we're
complaining. We're okay." So then he
just did, watch the flip. And you guys
pay attention when Muslims do this cuz
they flip-flop terms. They act like
being is personhood and personhood is
being. Okay. So, what he just said is is
that um okay, since we're talking about
being, it depends on his father. Okay.
Uh uh does the is the son generated by
the father? That's the personhood. So,
that's a relational property of hypoasis
or personhood, not the essence. Oh, I
see. So, you're telling me the
personhood needs to be generated? Yes.
The person is generated by Why? Why is
the father's personhood not generated?
Because he's the father by by the
because he's the father. What kind of us
is that? Because he's the father. Okay.
It's like let me let me give you let me
give you a complete answer. You said let
me give you a complete answer please.
Okay. Let me give you a complete answer.
Okay. So it's like saying this if you
ask why is the father the father? That's
like asking why father. Yeah you did.
You said I asked you why does the father
why is the father not generated? You
said I didn't ask you the father's
father. Okay. Okay. Why is the father
not generated? And I gave you the answer
is because he's the father. That's his
identity. That's not and and then you
said that's not an answer. So if I ask
you uh why is Allah all knowing? Oh
because he knows all things. He's all
knowing. He's God, right? We don't have
problem like the trinity. Oh yes, you
do. Answer the
question. You have the problem. We don't
have problem. Allah we don't say no. Why
is all knowing? We don't say our God is
three persons whose coin is and he he
needs a father to Why is he all knowing?
No. Wait. Why is he all knowing? You
realize you lost. No, I'm I'm I'm
showing you a hypocrite. You said you're
dependent on your father and mother for
why does Allah annoying for you being a
being. You depend on other beings. Why
is Allah knowing Jesus depends on
another being father? His existence
depends on the father. Don't change the
topic. Hashem don't change the topic.
I'm not look. All right. Hey guys,
ladies and gentlemen, he thinks that or
he's accusing me of changing the topic.
What I'm doing is applying his logic to
him. I'm not Hey,
I'm come Let me let me do this please.
I'm right here on the topic. What I'm
demonstrating is that your method of of
of uh breaking this down is
hypocritical. Okay. So when you say that
when I when you ask why is the father
not generated and I say because by
definition he's the father and you say
that that's not a father is the one who
generates. He's not generated. Can the
father be father generates the father?
No. Can the father be father? No. So it
is necessary for it's necessary for him
to be to generate to be the father.
That's the point. It is necessary for
it's a hypothetic property. So you're
saying you're saying you're saying
fatherhood is a necessary quality. It's
a necessary quality. Yeah. So for whom
this is what we're this is what we're
breaking down for for for the hypoasis
of the fraternity of the father because
he generates and I broke this down
earlier. Because God is relational in
his essence because he is love he
generates another person. Necessary
property for whom? Just answer that
question. Forgot. Forgot. So no father.
No answer. I said the father
specifically. I said the father
specifically. Oh my goodness. Stop
interrupting me. Hashm. Hashem. Stop.
Calm down. Stop. Let me answer the
question. You got Let me answer. No.
It's not. Holding on. You got to let me
answer. Okay. It's a necessary property
for Okay. Good. Paternity is a necessary
property of the father. Okay. Let me let
me finish, bro. Let me finish. I just
want to confirm. Let me finish though.
This is You're looking bad right now.
This is panic. No, you're not. You're
the one panic. Okay, you say you say
that. I'm letting you speak. You can't
even like go two words without. Okay,
good. So, according to notice this, he
didn't answer the question when I asked
him is Allah all knowing and why is he
all knowing? He wouldn't answer the
question because his answer would be
he's Allah. He's God. Now, if I would
don't put words in my mouth. Okay, then
answer the question. Why is Allah alone?
Again, first you answer the question.
Okay. First you answer the question with
regards to the problem. So right now
right now look look okay look okay look
okay look okay look okay look okay look
at right now the topic is on
Christianity okay and you need to stick
to that topic I know you're panicking I
asked you very clearly the property of
existence that is something which is
predicated on the person now we have
already established this you had no
answer to that what are you talking
about yes the property existence now is
predic
predicated to the
person to the existence of a person
being existence Yes. So stop saying
person. Existence is predicated of
existence. I say you're stumbling now.
You're stumbling now. You're stumbling
now. I say you're not. The reason I'm
not. It's because of all that noise in
the back. Can you tell these guys to
Yeah. Yeah. Guys. Guys, guys. Guys,
guys, a safety is a property which is
predicated upon brothers. Please ignore.
We don't need seven times. He didn't get
to I'm not evening all
guys chill man do not agree with each
other okay you ask me why is Allah name
okay Allah has attributes is
okay you know hold on hold on I'm
answering okay let me finish
his beautiful names and attributes are
something that all Muslims know about
Allah so for you one of his attributes
is all knowing why okay it's an
attribute why attributes are essential
of Allah Oh, essential. So, so because
he's Allah, he's all knowing. No, no. I
said attribute of Allah of all knowing.
Why? Because only God has this problem.
I'm not done yet. I'm not done yet. I'm
not done yet. I'm not done yet. So, I
You know, you know how this started.
This is crazy right now. Are you going
to interrupt? No, I'm I'm sorry. I just
got, you know, it's just it's just
steaming right now, bro. It's steaming
right now. No, it's already it's already
bad. Okay, so listen to this. The reason
he brought up this point about Allah's
uh attribute of all knowing is because I
asked him is the father the only one who
generates and he said that's an
essential property of God. I said the
father what the father is. So the
essential property is a necessary
property. Yes. Is it the necessary
property of God or not? Yes. Of the
father. Generation is a necessary
property of the father. I'm asking is a
necessary property of God? Yes. Of god.
Yeah. Of the Yeah. The being. Okay. The
being. The being. Asi is self-existent.
Yeah. Okay. Which means you have no
source. You are the one for your
existence. Right. Exactly. So So you're
saying
so according to you is is predicated to
your to your being. So you do not rely
on another being for your existence. No.
No. I said a safety is predicated upon
the person's existence.
Get me out of here. Get me out of here.
Come on, Hashem. Hashem, come on. I've
repeated it several times. As is
predicated upon the person's existence,
which he doesn't understand still. No,
you don't understand it. Because even
the church, you don't know what you're
doing. Even the church fathers agreed.
Only the father is they agreed. Oh my
god. He's the one who's going against
the church fathers. Who now? I don't
remember the name exactly. You can go
and find out. You can go and find out.
Just can I respond to this really quick?
Just no. No, wait. You need to
understand what I'm trying to say. You
said is a necessary property of God.
Yes. Necessary. So when I asked you,
does the father generate the son? You
said yes. In fact, you went even further
than that. You said he's the source of
both the holy spirit and he's the source
of the essence. Yes. Source. Source of
both of the essence. Because how can
Okay. Can you have essence without a
person? Yes. A rock. A rock. Yeah.
Without a person. Yeah. Hold on. You
earlier, this is why I said we need to
slow this down. Earlier you said that a
rock has essence has being but is not a
person. So you can have essence and not
personhood. Good. So you can have
essence and not person. Yes. Good. Does
an entity require an essence for his
existence? An entity is an essence? No.
Entity is not an essence. What do you
say entity? Is an object.
What? Yes. An object. Oh. So So okay.
For the existence. Look, I'm just saying
you need to differentiate between the
object and its existence. Okay. How do
you how do you do that? Very simple. If
you exist, let me ask you this. Is a
unicorn I'm lost, bro. Existence. Is a
unicorn a being? Is a Is a unicorn a
being? Are you like in reality or answer
the question? I'm just I don't We
realize now we realize the definition.
Is a unicorn a being? Okay.
Hypothetically, yes. Unicorn.
Hypothetically. Yeah. So, is it real or
not? It's not real. But thank you. So
you can be unreal and still be a being.
No. That is why I'm saying that's why
I'm saying don't use don't use this
funny term because in order for
something to
exist no
existence. Existence can be like you
said something which is hypothetical. I
didn't say that. I was going with you.
You said hypothetically. No, you said
agree with me. No. No. Cuz you were you
asked me
hypothetical you. You Oh my gosh. Oh my
goodness. You said hypothetically. Yes.
Oh my goodness. On camera. Oh my god.
This is bad. This is bad. All right. Let
me let me just respond to this dude.
God. At least I'll give you time to
correct yourself. Okay. So So Hashem,
once again, Hashem, is the unicorn being
I heard you. I heard you. So when you
asked, is is the unicorn a being? I
asked you in reality and you just said
just answer the question. So I'm I'm
assuming you're talking about in reality
and and and for the sake of argument is
hypothetic hypothetically saying that a
unicorn exists. I never said in reality.
Okay. So it doesn't exist in reality.
I'm asking you if it if it doesn't exist
then it doesn't have being. You know if
it doesn't exist it doesn't have being.
In fact it needs to exist for it to be a
being. Now you're saying yes. That's
what being is. Being is existence. Good.
existence has to be in real. And this is
what I'm trying to understand. In order
for Jesus's existence in in order for
Jesus's existence, does he require the
father? Say that again. In order for
Jesus's existence, does he is it
dependent? Is it contingent on the
father? Yes or no? Okay, let me answer
this guys. Notice the difference that
and this is what is not clicking for
him. But you guys get it. That's why you
guys are reacting to this. You guys get
it. You guys don't get The father
eternally generates the son. Correct?
That is a relational property between
the two. Okay. Hold on. Let me finish.
That's not that's that's relational.
That is not a property of essence.
That's a property of personhood. Okay?
So that's relational. Being the father
is a hypoatic property. Okay? Not an
onlogical property. Now hold on a
second. Let me finish. I'm trying to
help you. Okay? I am I'm trying to help
you. Okay? So don't understand. So when
you ask is the father the source of the
son? Yes, he generates the son but they
have the same being. So the in in the
generation this is this is a hypoatic
property a relation. Okay. But as when
it comes to their being they have the
same being. The father is not a
different being that generates another
being. Okay. That's why it's distinct.
Let me finish. No. Oh my god. That's why
it's distinct. No. It's okay. It's okay.
It's okay. It's okay. It's okay. It's
okay. It's okay. Jesus has two natures.
The father has only one nature. Let me
let me let me tell you why they're
distinct. They're distinct in their
personhood, not in their being. So
because the father generates the son,
that's a distinction. One is the father
who generates. The other is the son
who's generated. This is eternal, right?
This is relational. The son has soul.
The father has no soul. To be dependent.
Hold on, let me finish. To be dependent
is to rely on another being other than
yourself, other than your own being for
your existence. Jesus is not another
being. So therefore, he's not dependent.
Okay, good. Do you understand? Now you
said that they they have the same self.
But the father, the son, and the holy
spirit, they have the same self. Why are
we going? Cuz you said they're the same
self. I didn't say the same self. Oh my
god. I said the same being. Okay. So,
are they different? Contingency. Are
they different cells? No. No. Answer the
question. Wait, answer the question. Are
they different cells or the same? They
are distinct persons. What do you What
do you mean by self? What do you mean by
self? What do you mean by that? In terms
of existence, in terms of so he's going
he's going back to going back to being.
I will finish. You're back to being. No,
no. Self means your consciousness. So
personhood. No, consciousness. So is
that personhood? Is that
person is that personhood? Is that
personhood? Consciousness is is
predicated on the person. Okay. So it's
personhood. Consciousness is predicated
on a person. So is personhood. Existence
is predicated on a person.
Yes. No, it's not. Okay. Remember he
said that remember the example of the
No. No. Go ahead. Say it. Of the
unicorn. Just for everyone to know. He
said that the son is contingent on the
father. You need help? I don't need
anything. You
have him. You
[Applause]
woke up.
I can go out. It's not your people.
These are
everybody. He said something. I didn't
ask him either. He just stepped out. So,
can you tell him not to? No. No. He said
something. Okay. Well, I didn't say one.
I said one to one. We were But you let
him jump in. saying, "Look, if you
really needed help, that's what you've
been receiving. I've been I've been
helping you out. You've been needing my
help as well." And you needed his help.
Guys, guys, look, that's one to one and
then we can But why didn't you say that
when he jumped in? Why didn't you? I
didn't ask him. Why didn't you stop him?
Bro, you said come on to him just now.
No. No. That's after you. That's after
you rejected him. That's after you
rejected him.
Because he's losing it. He is a one v2
this whole time. Now s is
here. I want to hear what he's saying.
No, not really. No, you're confused on
the point. Okay. All right. How about
this? Let's let's let's get this
together. When you say self, are you
talking about personhood or being?
Consciousness is predicated on a person.
Do they have one consciousness or
multiple? That's what I'm asking. Is
self personhood or is self being? Self
has to exist. Oh my god. So it's being
Can I finish? Can I finish? Wait. Do you
have consciousness? That's what I'm
going to ask. No, you got to know. You
got to answer that question. Look, look,
I need to I need to I need to work for
you to understand. No, my question is
very simple. Is self personhood or is
self being? I've already answered that.
No, you didn't. I said self is a
consciousness which is predicated to a
person. So repeat. All right. So just
give me a yes. Answer the way. My answer
is correct. No, give me a yes. Yes, bios
is great. You need to realize is that a
yes to yes is person that I need to
understand. No, no, you need to
understand. So you So is a yes person
understand what predication means. Is a
yes person. You understand what
predication mean? No. Break it down for
me. Okay. You in order for your
consciousness even to exist. In order
for my consciousness to exist, yes, it
needs to be predicated to a person. You
didn't find what I I'm not understanding
this part everything. Can you have
consciousness without Okay, this listen.
Can you have consciousness without a
person?
Uh person should have consciousness.
Good. So it's predicated to the person.
Okay. Good. So person so person is the
self. Okay. Self is consciousness not
the person. How many times
repeat? No. I don't need your help. Do
you need your help? I don't need my
help. Do you need help? You don't need
my help. Do you need his help? Take a
drink. I don't want him. I don't want
him doing here's the problem. Okay. This
is
why the son is contingent on the father
purely because the son generates the
father. Here's what I'm going to say. He
can't tell you what contingent means.
Here's my problem. Contingent for
everyone means there is a world, okay,
where you exist, okay, and the thing
itself that made you doesn't exist. They
have the same. Answer the question. No,
that doesn't follow. They have the same
thing. No answer. I ask you two of them.
You haven't you haven't divine self. I
just told you consciously. So that means
personally predicated on the person on
Allah. He wouldn't be able to answer. I
don't have to answer your question. I'm
talking I'm debating this guy. Yo, is it
on hand?
[Applause]
Thank you very much.
Sorry. Ghost of paprika in here. Have a
ghost
every two. You jumped.
a different tangent to answer my
question. Do they share the same self or
they have their own do they have
individual selves? Okay. So since you
said that self is is predicated to
person is a consciousness. Yeah. And you
said do you need the mask guys? Really?
Do you need the mask? Okay. Once again
look I I let me answer your question
bro. Yeah. You need to understand the
terms because you seem to be I mean you
keep flipping the term you keep flipping
them. I've been consistent. Self is a
consciousness. Remember that. So is that
person is that person? So what is self
is a consciousness which is predicated
upon the person. Okay. So
so when you say when you say self this
is why we need to understand this
bro. When you say self it has nothing to
do with the essence. Correct. What's
that? It has nothing to do with the
essence the being. Right? Self. Self.
Self. In order for you to be conscious,
you need to exist. That's not the
question. Oh my god. That's not my
asking you because look, I said it's
dependent. Yes. And they're both one is
predicated on the other. You can look
your consciousness doesn't float in the
predicated. It is something predicated
on your personhood. Hashem, this is what
I'm asking. Even when you die, listen,
even when you die, your flesh is no
more. Is self that person? This is what
I'm asking. Because self consciousness
is is predicated to you. Okay, I hear
you. Is self a property of personhood or
is it a property of essence? self is
predicated upon the person. That's not
answering my question. Is it appropriate
person? Okay, fine. Is that so you're
saying it's a person? Why you think
because you didn't say that? You're not
answering me directs understood. You're
not answering me directly. Chef, like I
said, yeah, he has to interpret for you.
You got an idea. I said I said very
clearly how many times five times. The
reason he lost is because he doesn't he
doesn't know the the reason why I'm lost
is cuz you're lost cuz you keep flipping
your time. Everyone can lose. Everyone
is a The good thing about today is it's
recorded. Yeah, I know. a blessing.
Alhamdulillah. In the trinity, is it one
self or multiple selves? Okay. Since
you're saying that self is predicated to
personhood, then I would say that
there's there's distinct selves within
the essence of God because there's
distinct persons within the essence of
God. Okay. So, you have there are three
underlying realities of the essence.
That's what the Bible says.
Consciousness. Yeah. Exact. Exactly. You
have to define these terms. I said I've
already said what does consciousness
mean? Self. So, consciousness. So, it's
person which means person. You know
what? According to telling you what I
mean the
same. He's asking the same thing I'm
asking asking you. I asked you the same
question. No, you're not. You keep
flipping turn. You need your assistant
chef. Okay. It's consciousness
personhood. It's consciousness
personhood. Alhamdulillah. It's
consciousness personhood. Tell Look, you
keep asking the same question because
you keep flipping. No, I don't answer
it. How did I flip? Tell me. How did I
flip? I'll tell you how you flipped.
Okay. Because you keep saying that self
is predicated to existence. Then you say
self is predicated to person. So one
self is consciousness. Now keep that in
mind. Write down self is consciousness.
Write it down. And what is
consciousness? Hold on. Hold on.
Consciousness. Your ability to for
example you know do said that I I think
therefore I exist. Okay. So your ability
to think that you're conscious. You know
that's not today AI is not conscious.
basically a bunch of lines of lines
which they
actually based on that. Now you
consciousness you guys don't know what
consciousness I'm asking. You're not
telling us you don't know what it is.
Okay. What is it? I answered it. No, you
didn't. What is it? I mentioned you as I
mentioned. I quoted somebody. I So I
think for socious I think so. Therefore
I am right. So according to that
statement is c is consciousness equal to
personhood? It's predicated. How many
times have to repeat this? How many
times you're a bad chef and you're a bad
selfkick? So now you're not telling us.
You're not giving us the answer. What is
your definition of consciousness? No,
don't ask me. You use this. Wait, we
didn't. We didn't bring this up.
Somebody asked me the definition. We
didn't bring this up. He asked me the
definition of being. I gave him exact
cuz you're bringing this up. But he
doesn't answer my question. Now, what
are you talking about? Consciousness. If
you guys don't know what's conscious I I
told you what being was. I told you what
personhood was. Let me finish. Let me
finish. You're the one who brought up
consciousness and self. You're bringing
these new terms. So therefore, let me
finish. So therefore, you have to define
them so that we can continue. So we've
been stuck here for the past 10 minutes
because you're unable to define
consciousness. You don't know the
meaning of consciousness. Tell me. Tell
me.
What? Okay.
What happened? Okay. Now you answer. Is
self-awareness person? No. Now you
answer. What is question? It's self
awareness person. I'll give you the
answer. You answer. Okay. I got you. I
I'll go with you. Okay, I'll go with
you. No, you go with I'll go with you. I
don't know how yours. It's yours. It's
yours. I'll go with you. I'll go with
you. I'll go with you. I said, "Oh my
god." So, okay guys, look. Notice this.
Was according. It's okay. You can It's
okay. You can look it up. So, guys, you
can look it up, guys. It's okay. So, he
says both of them. Hashem, come on.
Hashem, you got Come on, bro. You're
looking bad. So, guys, now that let's
let's try to progress now cuz we just
been arguing terms. He says that
consciousness equals selfawareness,
right? Self-awareness. So because the
father is a person who's self-aware, the
son is a person who's self-aware. The
spirit is a person who's self-aware.
There are three hypoasis that are
self-aware. Okay. So there are three
persons within the essence. The question
was this because you mentioned each of
the persons of the trinity are
self-aware. Yeah. Basically that's a
point. Yeah. They are self-aware. The
question is this. Is the consciousness
one or three? Oh my goodness. So good.
You just you just said you just said
that the consciousness is being
self-aware and because they're let me
finish. My definition from the
dictionary it says the state of being
aware of and responsive to one's aware.
So dictionary.com but it's okay. Let's
go. Let's go. I'll take you on. It's
okay. Let's go there. Being self-aware.
No, no, let's let's go what you're
saying. So being self-aware, right? So
because according to his definition that
there's three persons that are
self-aware, there are three persons who
are conscience, right?
Now notice this question because they're
persons and they're self-aware. Since
he's saying that this has to do with
their personhood, this is a property of
their persons. It has nothing to do with
their essence. So this is not has to do
they're not
dividing them being. You got to let me
talk but you're not answering the
question. I I am I'm literally talking
to you. Okay. If you say no notice
notice that waffling is dealing with his
point directly. Notice notice that this
no you're not it's not a philosophical
one. It's not a philosophical
philosophical. So this is what all of
them I got. So because
guys yeah no he's in this. He's in this.
He's in this he's in this
step. He's He's here.
Everyone
everyone everyone be quiet.
Okay. Question still
remains do the trinity share one
consciousness or does each person have
his individual consciousness? Yeah, I I
appreciate that. So guys, stop it. Stop
it. You can't. Well, Jesus called you
dog. So why you so worried about it?
Well, yeah. Yeah, Jesus told you. Okay.
Anyway, so answer the question. How many
times do they do they share one
consciousness or does each person of the
trinity have individual consciousness?
Very good. Did he
please if they're going to heckle ignore
their
heckling shouting my ears? He's shouting
my dog again. I'm going to talk again.
If you shout again, guys. Guys, nobody
shout where we are. If you shot your dog
40 minutes on
this behave yourself I don't want this
one. That's it. Yeah. All right. So,
this is where we're at, guys. And I
think that I think that because I think
that because of this, guys, he hasn't
been able to demonstrate that the
trinity is illogical. He We had to teach
him what certain terms were. So, now in
talking about consciousness, I want to I
want to show you guys what he's trying
to do. No, no. Answer the question. I
am. Now, be quiet, please. What is the
question? Can you can you please be
quiet? Be quiet. Okay. Can you please be
quiet? Can you please tell me what the
question? Your question is are there
three different consciousnesses or do
they have the same consciousness? Okay.
So, this is what he's trying to do. He
said that consciousness, the definition
of consciousness just means being aware.
So, because there's three distinct
persons who are aware, there are three
that are aware. Okay? So, they have
their that these are these are distinct
persons. They have the same mind because
they have the same essence. However,
based on his definition of consciousness
on his definition,
I want your definition. When did we
define it? No, exactly. I want your
That's why That's why you're afraid to
define it because you know you lose
afraid to define it. We don't use the
term so we don't need. You brought up
the term being. You defined it. But we
didn't bring up the term conscious but I
brought it. So you need to define
because you're defining it. I did
already. Give me your definition. Bring
your definition. So guys, so guys, so
guys, yes. No contest now guys. The guys
are stepped out guys. Hold on. Hold on.
It's okay. So because Hashem has
gracefully given us a definition of
consciousness which means simply to be
aware to be self-aware because within
the the essence of God there are three
underlying realities rational realities
that are aware. There can be three
according to his definition.
consciousness. However, that doesn't
mean that there are separate
entings or essences. Right? There are
not. Let me finish. There are there are
not different essences or different
beings because self-awareness according
to him is a property of person not
being. So, still you have not
demonstrated that the trinity is
illogical or doesn't make sense. If you
don't define the term,
you're already he asked me. At least I
wasn't afraid. He asked me to define
terms. Yes. Even the term a satiety he
defined. It's not in the Bible. But he
defined it. You know why he's afraid to
define that term consciousness? Because
he'll realize that the three do not
share the same consciousness.
By your definition, they don't. Give me
those. By your
definition why in order for you to
understand this, you have to define your
definition. Exactly. Neither is a
neither is so here's here's the thing.
So basically no, you just spoke. You
just spoke. No, no, hold on. Come on,
bro. You just spoke, man. You spoke more
than me. No, I did not. All the
Christians don't don't want to admit
whether that god is conscious or not.
He's not even self-aware. Each
individual person is self-aware. But the
whole thing don't share the same
consciousness. You know when you have
multiple conscious when you have
multiple definitions consciousness is
literally being sent. This is called
multiple personality nature. multiple
said is that it's self simply just means
having a personal relationship which is
a mental
be something which the psychologist will
treat. So the fact that you don't want
to even tell us the definition of
consciousness because you realize you
have dug yourself in a hole. Okay. So so
notice this ladies and gentlemen we we
go with his definition of consciousness.
No no he can I
finish I'll let you speak. I'm going to
repeat yourself. I let you speak. Yeah.
Are you going to repeat? I'm going to
respond. I'm going to respond to you.
But are you going to repeat it? You just
repeated yourself. No, I didn't. I said,
"You give me You got to You got to let
me talk." If you don't give the
definition, then I'm move to the next
one. Okay, that's fine. That's fine. So,
Hashem here, he's bringing up words that
we don't use and trying to make an
argument based on these words. So, what
we did was say, "What do you mean by
that, Hashem? What do you mean by that?"
Now, and after 20 minutes, we finally
got a dictionary.com definition. I got
it before that. Let me finish. I got it
before. No, you did not. Watch the
video. I got it before. He's lying
again. Let me finish, bro. It's okay,
Hashem. It's okay. Logos. Logos. Yeah,
Logos doesn't lie. Logos. It's okay. All
right. So,
now he gave us his definition and his
definition. Now he doesn't want us to
work with his definition because he now
sees that there's not a problem when we
apply his definition. He didn't because
of his definition. He can't go where he
really wants to go. He really wants to
go. Let me finish. Stop running. Let me
finish, man. Stop running. Come on,
Hashem. Hashem, you're running. You're
running. I gave every definition. You're
running. You're running. Come on,
Hashem. Come on, Hashem. He wants to he
his argument that he's trying his
hardest to get to. He's trying to show
that the persons have different minds
and then therefore are different beings.
But because he got stuck with his own
definition, he can't even get there. You
wish. That's why you're afraid to answer
my question. What is the definition of I
haven't finished? So with your
definition, it helps me and there's no
problem. And I'll go with you. No
problem acknowledging that if uh by
consciousness, you mean just simple
self-awareness. So it has nothing to do
with the nature but has to do with the
personhood. Then therefore there can be
three that are self-aware and it's not
definition of consciousness. No answer.
Okay. Now that you already gave it.
Yeah, I did. But you did because you
kept Why do I have to give something?
Because you realize you brought it up.
You know why I asked this question. Can
we move on? Yes. You know why I asked
this question? I wanted to show you how
the father and Jesus are not the same.
Because not the same word. Stop
interrupting. Not the same word. Not the
same word. Stop interrupting. Not the
same word. Stop interrupting. Stop
interrupting. I know, but you got to be
clear. I will, but if you let me finish.
Okay, look. By the way, can you tell him
to stop interrupting the Muslim? You
stop interrupting. All right, Hashem.
Not the same. What? I will let me finish
so you'll hear. Okay. All right. He's
about to interrupting both of us. All
right. He's about to tell us not the
same. Jesus and the father are not the
same. What? Because Jesus is dependent
on the father. Not the same. What? Okay.
I don't tell you to let me finish. You
have to answer. There's part of that you
don't understand. You got to answer. How
are you going to answer? What is
consciousness? You said that you were
there. You already gave that. You
already definition. You already gave it
to me. You already gave the definition.
You already gave it. Now that God, they
realize that they don't share the
consciousness. Each person is
individually conscious because he went
with my definition. Not the same what I
said consciousness is predicated to the
person. Not the same what he did not the
same. Not the same what? Not the same
what? Not the same what the same
conscious not the same consciousness.
Not the same conscious. Okay. Thank you.
Good. So now you realize that they don't
have the same consciousness. So they're
not the same person. That is the reason
they both do not have the same knowledge
either. You know why? What? No. Yes.
Jesus. And they do not they do not in
fact even have the same nation. I'll
tell you why. Because this Jesus when he
was asked about the last hour he
He said that the father said he said
only the father in heaven. That shows
that they don't share the same
consciousness. Okay. Now Jesus unless he
was telling lies he he was asked
specifically do you know the hour. And
Jesus says nobody knows the hour. Not
the not the angels in heaven. Okay. Not
the son meaning himself except the
father in heaven. He distinguishes the
knowledge that he has from the father.
That's the reason I say they don't share
the same consciousness. And if they
don't share the same consciousness, then
their existence even is not something
which is the same because the father
exists is self-existing. The son is
generated like he said. Okay. He's
existed because he kept saying it is the
sorry the essence. No, the existence is
always existing. But the existence
depends and is predicated on the person.
You cannot just have existence floating
in the air. Existence is predicated on
the person whether living or on the
non-living because a non-living thing is
also a being like you said correctly.
But in order for the long you need to
have a rock to define his existence. So
it's pedicated to the object. Is the
rock a person? You don't need to be. So
you don't need a person for existence.
No. I said in order in the case of Jesus
it was a person existence. Do you need
him bro? Let him let him. You don't need
him. Are you stop?
So what I'm saying is Jesus did not know
the last command unless Jesus was
telling lies. Quick standard and they
say they say father sorry they said
Jesus is fully God fully man. Now in
order for you to be a fully man and a
fully God you need to be all knowing.
Okay. Now he's going to you know what
he's going to do? He's going to separate
the person, the who and the what the
nature which he told me all along not to
do. Watch now. Wait what? Separate. You
say you can distinguish. We should not
separate. Stop interrupting, man. What's
your problem, man? Finish, man. Do you
want him to interrupt? How you going to
say something to him? None of the
Muslims talk. It's okay. He's been doing
it even after you told him not to. So So
guys, um just calm down. I think I think
I think we should give some wrap
wrap-ups now because of this. Go wrap up
and you lost. Yeah. Well, okay. You say
that. Um guys, didn't I tell you what he
was trying to do? I called it right. And
by the way, I'm not a prophet, but I'm
I'm just as good as I think Muhammad
might be. No. Yeah. Not even. I'm
telling you. I mean, I did call it. I
called what you was trying to do. What
what he was trying to do is show what he
said by consciousness. What he really
meant was mind. But unfortunately for
Hashem, he gave us a different
definition to where it stopped him from
going to the mind argument. And now what
he said was is no. Oh, it's same thing.
It's not. I know you think
that. Hold on. Think about it. Well,
according to your definition of
consciousness, your definition was
self-awareness with our mind. Hey
brothers, can y'all stop talking behind
this? Please, please stop. Please. He's
cooked. He realizes he's cooked. Because
he defined uh consciousness by
self-awareness. He acknowledged that it
has nothing to do with the essence, but
it's a property of the person, your
personhood. So, it has nothing to do
with the mind, which is a property of
the essence. So, then he erroneously
brings up Jesus saying that he not
doesn't know the hour, which is
declaration, by the way, not cognitive
knowledge, but declaration. Hold on a
second. Well, that's the word o. That's
the word. Yeah. Don't interrupt me.
Don't interrupt me, please. Don't
interrupt me. Don't interrupt me. That's
Can you not interrupt me? Thank you. I
appreciate it. So, he tried to do that
and that's why he was trying so hard to
get here, but he couldn't because he
trapped himself with his own definition.
So, now what he showed was is that he is
uh philosophically unprepared to try to
demonstrate that the father and the son
are separate beings. He tried to do this
and he tried his darnest. He tried it
but he couldn't do it. And it's okay,
Hashem. So what you need to do, what you
need to do, it's okay. It's okay. Are
you Are you done? Not yet. Not yet. What
you need to do or mean? Oh. Oh, yeah.
I'll show you. Show me that. Yeah, it
means it didn't mean decoration. Yeah.
Okay, I got you. Look, I got you. So, he
wants All the Bible say knowing
decoration. Well, the the word no can
also be used for sexual activity as
well. Yeah. Show me how you Yeah, I got
you. Yeah. So, he wants to see that in
Mark 13:32, the word know, the word
oiden can mean to tell something or
declare something, right? So, I'm going
to show them this really quick. Yeah.
Mark 13:32. Yeah, of course.
Here it is.
Got the English translation for you
right here. Thank you. So, the father is
all knowing. Jesus is not and so is the
son. Jesus doesn't know the hour. John
16:30, the son knows all things. And
Jesus says, "Do you now believe?" No,
no. He says Jesus. So Jesus is saying at
one point he didn't know. Next point he
No, he doesn't say he doesn't. It's not
cognitive knowledge. It is not the same
nature. It's a change of knowledge.
Jesus is lying when he says I don't
know. It's not cognitive knowledge.
Jesus declaration. It's not for him to
make known. That's the father's job.
It's the father's which is what
Augustine says as well. I've checked all
the Bible versions. None of them say
declare. It all says he says he doesn't
know. Very clear. The term no is not in
all of them. Declare his name. None of
them. And I've got a Bible hub here
which gives you the different versions
of the Bible. I think there are
something like 60 or something. All of
them say the term no. None of them say
the word declare. This is now reading.
Special reading. All right, ladies and
gentlemen. Special bing. All right guys.
So ladies and gentlemen, so we got the
lexicon up. We got the concord
coordinates up. Strongs exhaustiffs
concordinates. I don't know if you can
see it camera, but this is what we might
put on the camera when we edit this. So
this is what it says, right? What's the
word that? Uh it's uh oid. What is it?
Ado. Yeah. Yeah. Ado. That's the root
word. No. Bring Mark 1332. Ado. Go to
Mark 13:32. When I look when I go to
Mark 13:32, I'm here. Mark 13:32, right?
And then here's the word oiden right
there. No. Yeah. You don't know. It's
the That's the
perfect click. I'm going to click on it.
And then it gives us all these
definitions. Right. Give us the
definition. I'm about to I'm about to
give you the strongest coordinates. Give
us the definition. It's right here. I
know. Before you go to both of them give
it both of them. The concordance gives a
definition. So it gives many. All right.
So this is what it says. Be aware,
behold, consider, perceive. Also
continuing a primary verb used only in
certain past tenses. The other being uh
borrowed from the equivalent I don't
know how to pronounce that properly to
see. All right. Properly to see. Yeah.
Right. To know is to see by implication.
To know, to be aware, to
behold, to
consider, have knowledge, to look upon,
to perceive, to see, to be sure. To
tell. Only when he picked. To tell. How
sincere. To tell. Does it say to tell?
There it is. Is that the truth? Does it
say to tell? Does it say? Does it say to
tell? Stop it. Tell this guy to stop.
Does it Does it say that? To tell. Wait.
Hashem, does it say to tell? Before you
go down. No. No. No. Does it say that at
the end? At the end of the I I didn't
read it. A primary verb. You're defining
a primary verb. Tell them. No. You're
defining the primary verb. But what is
the definition of the word? Use that. I
don't even know the Greek word. Does it
Does it say tell? Because you don't want
to tell me how. Why does he Why doesn't
he want to admit it? Does it say tell at
the end of the primary verb? It does say
but the verb used. What does it say
about the verb that used? Hold on just a
second. On the primary verb did what's
the word that did I demon? It's oiden.
So what does oiden mean? It it can mean
all of these things. One of them is to
declare. It means to tell. It means all
of those things. One of them is to tell.
To declare the word means exactly what
the Pharisees did. Oh my god. It means
all of those
things. The word is oiden. The word
oiden can mean different things
including to tell. Okay. So it's not
when you when you open
from the same from the same from the
same process
so guys guys it's not going to be
translated as tail. It's going to be
translated as no that's the word but the
meaning carried is going to be meaning
to tell someone. Now you're using the
primary verb but not the word that's
used in the what are you talking about
the word my turn now. So let me tell so
he used a primary verb but not the
actual word that is used in that
particular. So I'm going to do the same
thing I said. I'm going to mark 1332 and
I'm going to look at the term no in the
in the word in the parallel in the
parallel brick. Yeah, guys, he's
actually doing it for you, you know.
Stop talking. Listen, let's understand
what the Greek word means. Okay, 142.
Let's see the definition of the actual
word that's used there. It says here
very clearly. This is the It says be
aware, behold, ask can tell. Not tell.
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Not tell. Yeah.
Yeah. Not tell. It
says, "Keep reading. Keep reading. Keep
reading. Oh my gosh. Consider
[Music]
consider visual. Tell
[Applause]
Wait a minute.
After
this cooked, you got cooks. You got
cooks. You got cooks. You got cooks. You
got
cooked
tough question.
The question,
the question, the question is why did he
go to all the other words and only
choose the terms?
[Applause]
Okay. So now you know this is this is
called academic dishonesty and you would
actually have one word can have many
meanings but you choose only the one
that suits you. So Jesus is
saying Jesus I didn't say the term means
tell in that context term every are you
telling me all the Bible translators are
wrong and you guys are right. What they
agree with us they all say no. Oh my
gosh dude. The the word can be uh the
word can be used as no, but the meaning
carried behind the word no has different
meanings including to know by
declaration. I know. Why did they use
the term no not sell? They don't have
to. What? It carries the same meaning.
No, it's not. Yes, it does. Okay. Okay.
Like for example, for example, go
Hashem. Every single every single Bible
translation that I've seen, none of them
use the terms. So you guys can dance all
you want, but the thing is un if you're
going to say that I am wrong. Yeah,
that's what I was doing next. You have
to say all the Bible translators are
wrong. Okay. Are they all wrong? I've
got I've got Bible heart here. Let's
read what the Bible translates. Can I
give Can I give you an example? No. No.
Wait. It's my turn. Okay. I just want to
help you, man. Trying to help you. I
need your help. Okay. You do need my
help, bro. You need his help. I don't
need anyone's help. I need Allah's help.
Well, well, he abandoned you. Okay. So,
he left you hanging. Mark 13:32. He cast
you out. He gave him that. He gave him
Mark 13:32. All of them. And I'll bring
up every single Bible. This is now
nonpoint. There's not a nonpoint. Can I
Can I give you an example? Hold on. Let
me bring up Let me bring up the term
first. Okay. Okay. It's my turn. Now,
every single translation that I see
here, all of them have no Why does none
of them have the term tell? So if you're
going to blame that I got it wrong
because what he did was he picked one
word and he saw the different meanings
of that. But according to all the Bible
translator the only one that applies
that is no. Jesus was asked the question
does he know the hour? He clearly said
that he doesn't know the hour. In fact
if he says tell then the same thing
should apply consistently in the
passage. What does it say? The angels do
not know. Are the angels also going to
tell in the future? No. The son it says
nobody knows before the angels it says
nobody knows. So that means nobody. So
all of them are going to tell it the
future or they don't know. Of course the
only meaning that's the reason every
translation of the Bible we see Mark
13:32 they all translated as no not tell
or declare like the way these guys
wanted. So you do not this is called
false equivocation. You're equivocating
here is a fallacy and you're going to
look bad when you go and expose yourself
on camera like this. Okay? So, either
admit that all the translators are wrong
or you admit you're wrong. Okay? All the
translators are correct and you're
wrong. Okay? So, uh for some reason, I
don't know why this is going over your
head. The word can be used no. It can be
translated no and carry the meaning of
declarative, of telling something. It
can carry all those meaning to know by
perceiving, to know in seeing, to know
in understanding, to know in being
aware, to know in telling. All of those
can be know right now the hour. Now, let
me show you an example. Okay? So, in 1
Corinthians chapter 2, verse 2, this is
what it says. This is what Paul says.
Okay? A different verse cuz I need I
want to show you what I'm showing you
the same word. I'm going to show you I'm
going to show you how it's used. You
have to answer the question. I do I just
Why do all the translators? I
just translated. I want you to read
this. I want you to read this. Look, I
want you to read all of this. I look I
already did that. It's my turn now.
Look, I need you to read this. How loud?
It says, "For I decided," Hey guys,
listen up. Paul says, "For I decided to
know nothing." Are you paying attention?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. The same word is Oen.
Okay. I decided to know nothing among
you except Jesus and him crucified.
Who's Who's speaking here? Paul is Paul.
Does Paul know his name? Yeah. Does this
mean Does this mean that Paul doesn't
know anything? What are you trying to
imply from Muslim? No. I'm asking you a
question. What are you What are you
Because you brought up I'm showing you
an example. I'm showing an example of
the word no and how it's used. Okay. So,
when it says, so look, when it says,
"For I decided to know nothing except
Jesus and him crucified." Does Paul
literally not know anything else? Like
his name, math, his he's a Roman
citizen. Does he literally not know
anything else? You tell me. No, I'm
asking you, man. Tell me. I'm asking
you. I want to know from the same. I
need I need you to be I need you to be
like Come on. Come on. He said that the
words can mean in different places. Make
them make them answer. You got to answer
this. You did not ask the consciousness.
I'm going to answer that. Yes. Because
you realize it's a different verse. I
didn't bring up a different verse. Show
me from the same verse. Why do you have
to answer this question? Why do every
single uses the term no translating so
this is where I say watch your head
Hashem? Thanks for coming man. Watch
your head big dog. And this is why I'm
saying it. Let me answer. Let me let me
say my point bro. Why you cutting me
off? You need to answer my question. Oh,
I already did. I already answered it.
What was my question? Just just watch
the watch. You said, "Why do all the
translations translated as no?" That was
your question. No. Uh. Oh, I didn't.
Mark 13:32. I answered that already.
Mark 13:32. I already answered that.
Wait. Which translator uses the term
tell? They don't. Oh my
gosh. Anyway, it's okay. You know why?
Because
men tell. Let me say my point. Let me
say my point. You're right. I am done.
You're right. I'm done. So ladies and
gentlemen, what we have guys, ladies and
gentlemen, ladies and gentlemen, ladies
and gentlemen, this is a wrap up. We're
going to say thanks for coming to
Hashem. Thanks for coming, brother.
Let's clap it up for him. Let's clap it
up for him. Thanks for coming. Oh, man.
Look at Watch your head. Watch your hand
on the way out. Let me finish, brother.
Come on. I didn't interrupt you. Let me
finish. Every single verse,
what? What? We got to this point. No
problem. We got to the point where
Hashem got stuck and buried in his own
words, buried by his own definitions.
And this is why he could not he could
not demonstrate that the trinity shows
different gods that Jesus is separate
from the father, a separate being from
the father. He couldn't demonstrate it
by his own definitions. And then he had
to run to Mark 13:32 and then got
schooled on this. We showed him an
example. We showed him an example of the
word no being used declaratively. And
then because he got stuck, he refused to
deal with it. No, I didn't. The way you
refuse caution. He refused to deal with
it. This shows a weakness in your
position. So, I think this is a good
place to wrap it up. Say thanks for
coming and God bless. Hey, Jesus loves
you, man. Jesus loves you. Okay. Now, I
need to finish the finishing summary.
Okay. So we know that they evaded the
term and the meaning of the term
consciousness because they realized that
Jesus and the father do not share the
same consciousness. He said declare he
said tell about Mark 13:32. The reason
none of the Bible translators of that
verse not a different verse about Paul.
He changed not only the verse but he
changed even the person unless you're
telling me Paul is part of your
quadrinity or something. Okay. So the
reason he had to go to a different world
and this is what I said is a false equ
is a false a fallacy of equivocation and
this is a fallacy that they don't
realize they have done they were dancing
around to his show his circus he can
bring as many clowns as you want the
circus remains of him so what I'm saying
it's very clear the reason he did not
enter is Mark 32 32 and the term no
there okay the word can have several
meanings I don't I don't
actually however
I didn't interrupt you when you were
finishing. We did. We did. You did. You
didn't. So when you when you were pushed
to answer my question about why did
every single translator of Mark 13:32
uses the term no. And we know that the f
nobody knows the hour. Not the angels in
heaven, not the son, meaning Jesus,
unless he was telling a lie. Okay? Only
the father knows. Not only the father
tells because if you said only the
father knows it's about him being not
only omniscient but having a different
consciousness to that of Jesus. That's
the reason they are not the same
co-equal persons that they talk about in
the doctrine of the trinity which is
from the fourth century which is not in
the bible. The entire doctrine of the
trinity cannot be find. You cannot find
a three in one being in the bible. You
find it outside the bible. That's the
reason they did not bring up a single
passage to support the three in one
being. He kept saying that they have the
three they have the same existence. He
did not bring up anything to pro provide
a proof for them. He did not find a
single proof of them being even the same
consciousness which he didn't want to
admit. So he went to my definition. I
said the definition of exist sorry of
consciousness is something which is
self-aware and this is always predicated
to a person. So each person if they were
self-aware then they have their own
consciousness. That's the reason you see
the father having more knowledge than
the son. The son does not even know his
second coming. And that's the reason
Jesus says I can ofot myself do nothing
in John 5:30. Oh no. Come on. You can't
bring new
arguments. It's my finish. I can finish
the way I want. Not the way you like.
I'm not going to edit your video anyway.
So why you worried about all of this is
going to be in there. Yeah. Yeah. Sure.
Let me finish the way I want. Not the
way you want. Yeah, but you're bringing
them. So, we know that Jesus clearly
throughout his ministry, he was the one
who was worshiping his father. God the
father. The father never worships. Not a
lot. Yes, he does. Hebrew Hebrews 18.
You like the turn. You Hebrews Hebrews
18. Hebrews 1:9 says your your God. No,
it doesn't. That's not Hebrews. Hebrews
18 God. Hebrews
19b. Hebrews 19 says your God. Hebrews
18. Okay. But now says of the son. I'm
interrupting your life, oh God is
forever and ever. Hebrews 1:9 says,
"Your God to Jesus." Does Jesus have a
God? Cuz he has flesh. Does he have God?
He has flesh. God. Of course he has
flesh. Does he have a God? The God God
is the God of all. Does he have a God?
So because Jesus still flesh, the father
becomes his God when he enters the when
he enters flesh. That's it. But they
still have the same nature as God. Which
is why the father says that he's God
himself. Inter Jesus himself admitted in
John 27. You're bringing up different I
go to my father and your father. My God
and your God. And in John 27 uh 28,
Thomas says to Jesus, you're the Lord of
Jesus of me.
So he said he bar for
[Applause]
barriers. He says this is a night that
they may know you. The only true God.
Jesus is saying to his father, his God,
that you are the only true God and Jesus
Christ whom we have sent. First John
5:20, it says that Jesus is the true
God. We are in him who is true in the
son, Jesus Christ. That is the true God
and eternal life. About the father.
First John 5:20. It just said the son.
Yes. You go home and check it. It's
about the father. You go home and check
it. Because Jesus says in John 17, the
only true God is the father. It says the
son. Yes. Read it fully and I'll show
you why the father. Pick it up.
John, you know why they didn't bring
John 73? Because it's very clear. You
You didn't want to talk about Bible. You
You didn't ask about the Bible. Crypto
died of this trinitarian. We Hey guys, I
got the best. We can wash your mind if
you want. No problem. I got the best. I
got the best. I'm not talking to you.
I'm talking to you. I got the best. I'm
talking to you. Okay, I'll read it. I'll
talk to you. All right, I'll read it.
So, it says, "And we know that the son
of God has come and given us
understanding that we may know him who
is true." Here it is. That we may know
him who is true. Uhhuh. And we are in
him. Hold on. And we are in him who is
true in his son Jesus Christ. This is
the true God.
Every time every time you use him and
his it's about the father John.
He said it very clearly. That's why he's
talking about the father. You're done,
bro. Go ahead. No, this was good. Thank
you for the discussion. I appreciate it.
No problem. All right, ladies and
gentlemen, we just had a brilliant
conversation with Hashem. Now, guys, at
his in his conclusion, he started
bringing up different points that for
some reason he didn't bring up when we
were in the middle of the discourse,
right? So, I just want to answer and
clarify some things here. Okay? So, why
is it that it's not for the son or the
angels or even the humans to declare the
hour? And there's the reason. It's
because he says this is the authority
that belongs to the father. This is a
respect and a glorification that the son
leaves to the father. But guess what?
John 1:18 says this. It says, "No one
has seen the father at any time. The
only begotten god who is at the father's
side, he has made him known or declared
him." So whenever the father wants to
make something known, whenever the
father wants to declare something, he
does it through the son. So at about
that hour, even though it's not the
son's prerogative to make it known, when
the father is ready to make it known, he
does it through the son. That's what it
is. Now on top of that, the he says
this, the the apostles ask, "Is now the
time in Acts chapter 1, is now the time
where you're going to restore Israel?
Where you're going to restore Israel
back?" You know, they're asking about
the hour again. And he says it's not for
you to know the times or the seasons
that the father has fixed by his
authority. He doesn't say it's not for
us to know. He doesn't say guys I told
you I don't know already. He says it's
not for you to know. And by the way,
it's a different Greek word for know
there than it is uh when in Mark 13:32.
So notice how beautiful the Bible just
flows, right? The Bible flows
beautifully. Now it was like
Get up. Let me get up. He He
I'm so sorry, guys. I'm still going over
the word tail.
When he read the definition, man.
He had no idea what he was walking
into. He didn't think he was going to
say tail. So, he he got caught by his
horse. Notice what happens when you're
prideful, when you're arrogant, and you
you know, you put the cart before the
horse. You know what I'm saying? Just be
humble. ask questions instead of demand
things or else you get embarrassed and
then you end up on the chef's market,
you know. And and by the way, did he
answer our question of what the in jail
was? He didn't answer, right? So, let's
get another chant. What's the What's the
What's the What's the What's the What's
the
It's God. It's God. It's God the
[Music]